CBS News has confirmed that members of
president Trump's legal team have had
concerns about jared krishna's role as
senior White House adviser Wilfried
journal first reported that the lawyers
considered recommending that his
son-in-law leave they were worried about
his June 2016 meeting with the Russian
lawyer and Donald Trump jr. but Kushner
remains in the White House even as other
advisors have departed those departures
include former chief strategist Steve
Bannon he was reportedly at odds with
Jared Kushner in our sixty minutes
interview
Bannen shared his thoughts on Kushner
and the factions within the
administration
so you're saying HR McMaster and Jared
Kushner and Ivanka Trump even though
they opposed views that you had on
climate and on the Paris Accord yes they
have your full support and you hope
they're there in the White House
sticking up for what they believe in
absolutely I think Jared and Ivanka know
they stay I think there are terrific
people on the campus by the way and
their ideas as long as it
counterbalanced by the Peter Nevarez and
the Steven Millers and more the economic
nationalist I think will be fine as long
but I do believe and I've told the
president of this and the president
knows this that if he goes to his
default position and goes and follows
what he ran on and what he believes in
the core of his being okay not only is
he going to have a massively successful
first term he's gonna win a second term
by a much bigger majority than he won
the first and I think over 400 electoral
votes New Jersey Governor Chris Christie
is firing back at Steve Bannon for
something he said in our interview
Christie rejected bannon's version of
events following the release of the
Access Hollywood video during the
campaign mr. Trump was heard using bold
in a language about women Bannon said
Christie was told to be on the campaign
plane at a certain time as a show of
support but failed to show up Chris has
said that the so-called plane ultimatum
never happened he also said he was
offered cabinet position that he turned
down mmm so little he said he said the
plot thickens who to believe yeah I
heard Chris Christie said the other day
I've got Bert very broad shoulders I've
heard from people I've taken on stings
for
people far tougher than Steve banner
yeah who do believe I think he said
something like - I hope he enjoys his 15
minutes of fame smack-talk yeah well I
think he told you Steve Banta that I'm a
street fighter this is called a story
that has legs giving there will be more
of Charlie's interview tonight on his
PBS program it's called the Charlie Rose
show